ce président du congrès messieurs les
parlementaires monsieur président de
l'association des maires mesdames
messieurs les élus de la collectivité
territoriales de guyane mesdames
messieurs les maires mesdames et
messieurs les représentants des chambres
consulaires madame la présidente du
siisneq chers citoyens de guyane
mesdames messieurs bien que les immenses
richesses de la guyane soit
universellement reconnus ce territoire
continue d'engloutir des milliards et
des milliards sans la moindre
perspective d'avenir certains d'entre
vous ont reconnu un extrait de sos ici
guyane ce constat justin catayée l'a
fait au milieu des années 50 il ya plus
de 65 ans des décennies après nous
pouvons employer les mêmes mots dressé
le même constat la guyane reste
embourbée dans des projets de
développement sont jamais parvenir à une
véritable prospérité pour autant depuis
catayée nous ne sont pas restés les bras
croisés
les opales eder avait défendu au sénat
le droit de la guyane à disposer d'un
statut politico administratif qui lui
assure une plus grande autonomie
localement les élus parmi lesquels mon
père on devrait pour les états généraux
du développement réel et durable de 97
le document d'orientation d'un pacte de
développement pour la guyane adopté le
27 février
1999 et enfin on doit aussi citer la
déclaration de basse-terre du 1er
décembre de la même année signé par le
sénateur karam lucette michaux chevry et
alfred marie jeanne avant nous nos
prédécesseurs conscient de l'impérieuse
nécessité de réaliser cette réforme
politico administratives ont multiplié
les initiatives depuis cette date du 27
février 1997 99 ans ne saurait compter
le nombre de congrès qui ont été
organisées aussi je compte plus le
nombre de documents cadres rédigé après
tant et tant de réunions de travail je
contemple hélas le peu de chemin
parcouru après tant d'efforts tant
d'engagement nous ne sommes jamais
parvenus à donner à notre guyane les
outils indispensables à son
développement
s'il est vrai que l'état ne nous a
jamais facilité la tâche il faut avoir
le courage d'admettre que nous avons
aussi notre part de responsabilité en
tant qu'observatrice de vie de la vie
politique je me souviens de ce qui nous
indiquait qu'il était urgent d'attendre
aujourd'hui je leur demande avant nous
suffisamment attendu personne dans cette
salle ne peut prétendre que nous ne
sommes pas prêts nous le sommes depuis
bien longtemps personne ne pourra
affirmer aussi que le statut actuel de
la guyane est propice au développement
de ce territoire et répondre aux
attentes de la population
seules celles et ceux qui ont un agenda
politique dictée par des stratégies
électoralistes et des calculs
politiciens à court terme peuvent
affirmer que la question statutaire
n'est pas prioritaire et pourtant nous
devons avoir de l'ambition pour notre
pays pour ce qui me concerne je souscris
pleinement un changement de paradigme
sans pour autant renier le travail
effectué par nos prédécesseurs
fort heureusement nous ne partons pas
d'une feuille blanche et nous devons pas
respect et cohérence nous appuyer sur
les travaux menés depuis de nombreuses
années sur le principe je ne peux
qu'adhérer au projet guyane qui
s'inspire assez largement des textes
issus du projet de société de 2001
toutefois ce changement de paradigme que
j'appelle de mes voeux se situe surtout
dans la méthodologie l'une des
faiblesses des précédentes tentatives
réside dans notre obsession à vouloir
s'opposer frontalement à l'état comme
vous l'avez suggéré monsieur le
président nous devons faire veulent et
un partenaire dans ce processus
néanmoins le projet doit foncièrement
rester guyanais construit par les
guyanais pour les guyanais toutefois
nous devons instaurer une concertation
avec le gouvernement
cela permettra d'éviter ces écueils qui
ont desservi notre projet aussi cette
concertation pas un pas que l'état
pourrait nous permettre de gagner du
temps il est désormais urgent d'agir la
question de la consultation populaire ne
doit pas non plus générer des
frustrations au sein de la population
car indéniablement les esprits ont
évolué depuis 2010 à titre personnel
j'avais souhaité que cette question
figure dans les débats pour l'élection
présidentielle ainsi les électeurs
guyanais aurait pu choisir en
connaissance de cause malheureusement ce
calendrier n'était pas tenable enfin
évoquant brièvement le contenu du projet
qu'on se le dise l'autonomie ne doit
plus être rentable un tabou je sais que
ce terme fait encore peur l'autonomie
n'est pas l'indépendance c'est à nous et
à nous seuls de décider aujourd'hui où
nous voulant placer le curseur en
matière d'autonomie en ce qui me
concerne nous devons explorer de
nouvelles compétences qui permettront
d'élargir le champ de responsabilité de
la guyane mais et j'insiste là dessus il
est essentiel de rester ancré dans la
république
rien ne nous interdit de regarder ce qui
a été fait en polynésie française ou en
nouvelle calédonie sans oublier
l'exemple corse mais devant éviter de
tout copier car l'expérience nous a
démontré que notre guyane est uni pour
conclure j'entends me positionner en
tant que garant des décisions qui sont
prises ici aujourd'hui en tant que
sénatrice de la guyane je compte
m'impliquer personnellement dans la
poursuite des discussions avec le
gouvernement nous devons dans l'intérêt
de l'ensemble du peuple guyanais
transformer cette fois ci laissé
résolument optimiste je veux croire que
nous sommes aujourd'hui suffisamment
mature pour nous rassembler afin de
formaliser un statut qui consacre son
droit à la différence pro de temps passé
entre le cri du coeur de justin catayée
dont sos ici guyane jusqu'aux accords de
guyane du 20 avril 2010 est il est
urgent d'agir je vous remercie de
m'avoir écouté
[Applaudissements]